the boys season three is now five
episodes deep hey and slowly we are
starting to learn more and more about
one of the major characters aka soulja
boy not only is he a brilliant rapper
dance innovator and games console
inventor but he's now one of the most
dangerous soups in the entire show
played by jensen ackles this cat parody
definitely feels like he could be
america's ass and throughout this video
we're going to be breaking down his
comic origins the show differences and
what we think could be happening with
him jensen is of course one of the
co-leads of supernatural the legendary
long-running show which ended in 2020
and he's reunited with that series
creator eric kripke who's also behind
the boys a soldier boy is notable in the
comics for having multiple people under
the mask and a big moment in herogasm
whilst homelander and the seven are a
parody of superman in the justice league
soulja boy and payback are the avengers
corner of the boys this is why you see
clear satire to captain america scarlet
witch and a lot more the group he was
originally part of was called the
avenging squad so yeah no prices for
guessing who that's based on and the
comics had a modern soldier boy in
present day but during issues 52-54 we
learned the origin of the character and
the first person to take up the mantle
just like captain america and the marvel
universe there have been many people
that have taken up the shield and we've
had three versions in total two of which
that we mean the comics i like steve
rogers soldier boy was attached to an
army unit in the second world war led by
greg mallory who in the show is changed
up to grace the series did away with the
multiple versions and shifted the
timeline so that grace encountered him
in nicaragua where he was helping to
smuggle narcotics into the us whilst
also fighting alongside the locals the
show sort of combined all the visions of
the characters and in the comics it was
during the second world war skirmish
that the first one died however it
should be noted that the version we meet
in the show was also around during the
second world war ii and just like
stonefront he didn't age due to the
compound v that was created at the time
typically it's injected into pregnant
women or very very young children
however both stormfront and soulja boy
got it as adults which is likely why
they don't age like the rest of us
whereas she had a big twist that vort
did not see coming
soulja boy stayed true to the red white
and blue and while stormfront needed to
change her identity in order to hide her
immortality soulja boy in the show he
just kept going as liberty she was sent
off after being exposed as a racist but
because soldier boy didn't carry out any
crimes that meant he never needed a
rebrand and he just stayed the same
however both are gonna have awful
opinions and eccles has said that soulja
boy unlike steve rogers will have very
of the time views on social progression
now in the comics we never really get a
taste of this but we still learn about
his past and the history of the shield
now because the suits are pretty much
morons across the board they were
ill-equipped to be put into combat
scenarios but bought still wanted the pr
so they shipped them out to the front
line in the second world war similar to
the show the group ended up signposting
their location due to their arrogance
and inexperience in the comics this
happened during the battle of the bulge
and it caught the attention of a german
patrol the battle of the bulge is known
as one of the great ambushes in recent
memory and this surprise attack by the
germans was their last major offensive
in the second world war
most of the team of supes were wiped out
including the crimson countess who
survives the skirmish in the show now
mallory in the source material was the
sole survivor and he found soldier boy
at dead store blaming him for having his
entire battalion wiped out he tossed a
grenade at him killing him in the
process and whilst marvel's captain
america was frozen in ice to bring him
into the modern era bought higher-ups
use their considerable pr power to
rewrite history and make soldier boy an
immortal legend in reality though the
mantle would be passed on to multiple
soups over the following decades this
included the second version who is part
of crime fighters incorporated a group
that are basically just a rebrand of the
previous team this is only shown to us
in a newspaper in the comics and we
never meet the character at any point in
the run now we get a look at the current
holder of the title when he first
appears in the boys spin-off herogasm
it's a wild ride of debauchery that
would make even termite blush herogasm
is basically an annual event held by
vaught but they say that the soups have
gone off will to fight an intergalactic
threat what's really happened though is
that they've just gone to an island to
do a lot of drugs have a lot of sex and
also hit that thumbs up button now the
modern soldier boy is a coward and all
around just a useless individual that is
supposed to be the leader of payback
however he's very much just the face of
it and behind the scenes stormfront is
the one who's really pulling the strings
soldier boy doesn't swear he wets
himself and also names u.s states to
keep calm in battle this made many
theorize that ryan will end up becoming
him but whether that's the case we don't
know yet and the comic version would end
up fighting billy and the boys and this
led to him having his nose bitten off
later on he was killed by billy after
payback engaged them in issues 32-34
we'll talk about this more in just a bit
and in the comics he's desperate to join
the seven which makes him ample pickings
for homelander he's tricked into having
sex with him as an initiation task but
he never becomes a member whilst the
comic version is a hilarious take on
what would probably happen with a
real-life captain in america the show
has changed up quite a lot from the
source material and eric kripke and co
have really made it their own eric
mentioned soldier boy has been a big
part of ward for decades and we saw this
first hand due to his statue in season
2. in an interview on the michael
rosenborn podcast jensen gave some
details on the character that i haven't
really seen touched upon that much on
youtube and whereas the winter soldier
allusions to him being experimented on
are pretty obvious ackles also said that
he's very much a weapon x or rather
wolverine type character this is seen in
him waking up and pulling tubes out of
his body which is supposed to be
reminiscent of the weapon x issue 78
cover his suit is undeniably inspired by
the mcu captain america and it features
the green which is the same colours as
the 40 era's soldier boy costume now for
the more modern one's demise in the
comics payback was sent to take out
billy's team as a proxy for homelander
but it failed spectacularly billy bit
his nose off blinded stormfront who then
fled and the rest of the group were easy
pickings without their true leader
soldier boy was then killed but the show
seems to be diverting from this in the
series he's referred to his code name
bcl red or as i'm guessing it's called
big chess laser now this is highly
radioactive and it seems to be able to
either completely kill a soup or at
least wipe out their powers this is why
kimiko can no longer heal but it seems
to also be uncontrollable to soulja boy
he ends up killing several people in new
york no more do downplay this i think
that just in the same way captain
america came back after some time away
that they will try and spin it like he's
been on ice or preserved due to
radiation they set up a fake chernobyl
kind of cover story and could possibly
use this as a way to try and bring him
back into the fold at the moment he's
currently out to try and get payback on
payback but i think that board might try
and take him under their wing once edgar
is back what the company really needs is
someone who can reign homelander in as
at the moment he's completely off the
leash i think soldier boy could be the
person to do this and it's going to be
interesting to see why they got rid of
him in the first place perhaps he was
just becoming too powerful and they
wanted him off the board before he got
any more dangerous or perhaps the
company made a deal with the russians
this was during the cold war but for
don't care about sides they just care
about money i can see edgar being
someone who would still be up for
selling weapons to them and it's going
to be interesting once it's revealed
exactly what's really going on with the
character he actually seems like the
kind of person that could beat
homelander but whether he does remains
to be seen anyway that's our breakdown
and of course love to hear your thoughts
and make sure you comment below and let
me know we are running a competition
right now and giving away three copies
of everything everywhere all at once on
the 15th of july and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the
character we picked the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now so if that's you then message
me on twitter at heavyspoilers if you
want something else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of
season 3 episode 5 which will be linked
on screen right now we went over all the
comic book callbacks easter eggs and
also gave our thoughts on the series so
definitely head over there right after
this without the way thanks for sitting
through the video i've been poor let's
see in the next one take care peace